la guerre des abonnements de cinéma
reprend hier le conseil de la
concurrence a autorisé ugc à vendre sa
carte annuelle qui donne droit à des
séances illimitée réaction immédiate de
la ministre la culture en désaccord
catherine tasca a engagé une procédure
de sanction charlotte millet doc luc
et rebelote ugc reviennent à la charge
avec sa fameuse carte qui permet pour 90
lits francs par mois d'assister à un
nombre illimité de séance le
distributeur avait suspendu sa vente le
9 mai dernier suite à une plainte
déposée par les autres réseaux or le
conseil de la concurrence n'a pour
l'instant fait état d'aucune pratiques
déloyales
savez vous prenez une classe moyenne 40
francs
prenez encore notamment artistes et déjà
le prix pour
comme moi cinéphile je crois dans
cinéphile d'accord mais jusqu'à quand
les petits exploitants tire la sonnette
d'alarmé cette carte ugc en réalité
n'est pas une simple proposition
commerciale c'est une ouverture de
guerre des prix qui a en fait pour seul
but de prendre des parts de marché aux
autres concurrents et surtout aux
indépendants et là peut évidemment de
les faire disparaître car les petites
salles n'ont pas les moyens financiers
pour présenter la carte illimitée pour
les soutenir la ministre de la culture a
annoncé qu'elle prendrait des sanctions
financières contre le distributeur en
attendant elle prône la concertation
j'aimerais bien que j'essaie accepte de
se mettre autour d'une table de travail
avec les autres exploitants et
qu'ensemble ils trouvent que nous
trouvions des solutions
commerciales des solutions aussi
conventionnel de partenariat pour que
les pratiques commerciales qui peuvent
être très profitable pour les uns ne
soit pas nuisible à l'équilibré du
marché les petits se sentent menacés
mais les gros distributeurs préparent
déjà leur riposte l'un d'entre eux
s'apprêterait à sortir une carte
identique